[Music]
so let's talk a little bit about
inequality and what it is so let me ask
let me start by doing this how many of
you have have read Harry Potter alright
good love this audience already this is
good
now Harry Potter is a real problem when
it comes to inequality because I don't
know about you but I have calculated
that I have spent thousands of dollars
on Harry Potter I mean you can do your
own calculation but I had two sons they
were about how he's aged every time my
book came out I either I had to go stand
in line at midnight and get two copies
oh they you know and they got older got
to stand in line and get two copies each
hardback copies right because they
wanted the hot off the presses they
couldn't wait and they spent the night
reading it I also wanted to read Harry
Potter I loved the books so I had to get
them on audio tapes a third copy so
that's three times seven twenty one
multiplied by about twenty-five thirty
dollars do the math then there's the
movies what are they 67 movies because
they turned every book into two or three
movies to get as much out of us as
possible right so take into account all
the money you spent on the movies and
then add to that the Disneyland rides
and the all the other hobby Potter stuff
that we have had approaches to make our
children happy I spent thousands of
dollars I indeed if you look at my bank
account got poorer by thousands of
dollars because of Harry Potter but the
real evil here is not only did I get
poorer what happened to JK Rollins she
became a billionaire I mean give me a
break this is horrible inequality
exploded
I got poorest she got richer this can't
be good
we told we are taught we read in every
newspaper than inequality is a bad thing
well here's an example of it
quality she got rich I got punched she
got rich off of my back my money came
out of my bank account straight I mean a
few other people got rich in the
meantime right in the middleman but
straight into a bank account and yet we
all feel like there's something wrong
with this example right why why why
isn't it comfortable to say you know
this is a bad thing well because what
happened why did we spend those
thousands of dollars of Harry Potter why
did we spend it yeah cuz we enjoyed it
because it gave us pleasure because it
gave us certain spiritual values we
benefited enormously I I'm thankful to
JK Rollins if I met JQ on straw in the
street I would say thank you for letting
me spend those thousands of dollars no
I'm serious
I'm serious I would that's exactly what
I would say to JK Rowling is Wow
the pleasure you gave us is unimaginable
very few office have ever given us as a
family not just as a just for me
individually as a family so much
pleasure
so did I really get proba no I mean I
got poorer materially but spiritually I
think I got richer and I was happy to
give up those thousands of dollars cuz I
had fun I enjoyed it so I am richer for
the having Harry Potter and I don't I I
I'm happy that she got to be a
billionaire she deserves it she made all
of our lives better
she made the world a better place to
live and she got rich who cares life's
not about money I have to remind my
leftist friends of this because the left
seems obsessed about money but I don't
think likes about money I would rather
read the book than have the money in my
pocket I think most all of us would
that's why we gave up the money because
we believed let's say the book costs 20
does that the book the experience of
reading the book is more valuable to us
as individuals than the 25 dollars in
our pockets
and that's how inequalities created for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of
arson ideas at iai TV
you